was haben beispielsweise der
tasmanischen beutelwolf mammut und die
wander taube gemeinsam sie alle gehören
auf die liste der ausgestorbenen
tierarten und wir menschen könnten uns
schon bald ein rein dramatische
veränderungen auf der erde können uns
menschen schon in den nächsten 100
jahren als opfer fordern warum manche
experten und expertinnen genau dies
vorher sagen und wie ernst wer diese
warnung tatsächlich nehmen sollten
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei pixum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen
aber heute mit cedric von doktor watson
von allen tierarten die jemals auf der
erde lebten sind laut schätzungen
bereits jetzt rund 99 prozent
ausgestorben und schon in wenigen
jahrzehnten wird dies auch uns menschen
drohen zumindest wenn man den
mikrobiologen frank fenner glauben
schenken mag er hat schon vor einiger
zeit in dem fachmagazin für sark einen
bericht veröffentlicht der wirklich
alarmierend ist und einige entwicklungen
in den vergangenen jahren legen
tatsächlich nahe dass wir seine warnung
ernst nehmen sollten auf der erde sollen
sich fans vorhersage zufolge in naher
zukunft dramatische veränderung ereignen
die das aussterben der menschheit zur
folge haben könnten und kenner der 2010
verstorben ist ist keineswegs als
spinner in der fachwelt bekannt ganz im
gegenteil er war zeit seines lebens weit
über sein fachgebiet hinaus bekannt und
hat zahlreiche preise gewonnen
beispielsweise für seinen beitrag zur
bekämpfung von malaria in neu guinea
während des zweiten weltkriegs doch was
die zukunft der menschheit betrifft ist
der forscher wie gesagt alles andere als
optimistisch fans schon im jahr 2010 vor
allem den klimawandel als entscheidendes
problem
dieser stehe zwar erst am anfang doch
wird der laut tanner das aussterben der
menschheit zur folge haben
in seinem aufsatz vergleicht er unseren
untergang mit dem schicksal welches die
menschen auf der osterinsel erleiden
mussten
nachdem sich die ersten menschen auf der
eins tropischen insel angesiedelt hatten
wurde die bevölkerung erst langsam dann
immer schneller
die wälder wurden gerodet und viele
tiere sterben aus mit fatalen folgen
um 1600 herum brachte die zivilisation
zusammen und war mitte des 19
jahrhunderts komplett verschwunden
doch nicht nur fehler selbst sondern
auch andere experten und expertinnen
sehen parallelen zu den aktuellen
entwicklungen auf unserer erde
der klimawandel jedenfalls wird seinen
teil dazu beitragen
sich das leben verändern wird so viel
steht bereits jetzt fest der letztes mal
im jahr 2018 hat selbst in deutschland
gezeigt welche folgen uns blühen flüsse
und seen trockneten aus die spree hier
in berlin floss rückwärts die anhaltende
dürre führte zu ernteausfällen und somit
stehen weniger lebensmittel zur
verfügung als gebraucht werden aber auch
andere menschliche verhaltensweisen
könnten zum aussterben der menschheit
beitragen wie etwa die rodung von
wäldern um immer mehr infrastruktur zu
schaffen
pflanzen und tieren wird damit der
lebensraum genommen und das bedeutete am
ende auch für uns menschen weniger
nahrung auch den ozeanen könnte studien
zufolge schon bald der kollaps drohen
die überfischung der meere könnte schon
im jahr 2048 dazu führen dass keine
kommerzielle fischerei mehr möglich ist
dabei sind einige milliarden menschen
auf fisch und meeresfrüchte als nahrung
angewiesen
die kluft in der gesellschaft zwischen
arm und reich wird immer größer
feststeht zahlreiche menschen haben
nicht die möglichkeit sich selbst und
ihre familien mit essen zu versorgen in
zukunft wird die zahl der hungertoten
wohl noch dramatisch steigen auf der
anderen seite werden in ländern wie
deutschland unfassbar viele
nahrungsmittel weggeworfen und die
anzahl der fettleibigen menschen steigt
an und auch wasser selbst könnte schon
bald auf weiten teilen der erde knapp
und zum luxusgut werden
ein problem eben nicht nur für uns
menschen sondern auch für viele andere
lebewesen die britische zeitung the
guardian geht davon aus dass schon in
knapp 30 jahren zehn prozent aller
pflanzen und tierarten ausgestorben sein
könnten
darunter auch elefanten ob die
vorhersagen tatsächlich schon in kürze
realität werden kann wohl niemand mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit sagen
doch abzustreiten ist keineswegs dass
dringender handlungsbedarf besteht
wir alle können einen teil dazu
beitragen etwas zu ändern und unsere
erde und somit auch unsere eigenen
zukunft etwas gutes zu tun
ökologische nachhaltigkeit ist hier das
stichwort beispielsweise können der
verzicht auf fleisch und fisch das
vermeiden von plastik und allgemein ein
achtsamer und bewusstsein im umgang mit
konsumgütern dabei helfen die erde
langfristig zu bewahren und sie zu einem
sicheren ort zu machen an dem die
menschheit auch weiterhin die
möglichkeit bekommt zu existieren ja
vielen dank cedrick er ist derjenige der
auf youtube in die zukunft schaut und
jede zukunftstechnologie in zehn minuten
erklären kann also unbedingt seinen
kanal hier abonnieren also wie immer
draufklicken ansonsten bis dann
bleibt da dankeschön